- This is CNS 341.
You're in the right place
if you are a developer
that is looking for faster ways
to get your code deployed in AWS.
You are also in the right place
if you are a platform team
or infrastructure engineer
looking for patterns or guidance
of how to accelerate your teams.
My name is Jennifer.
This is Tsahi.
We are your ECS experts today.
We're also going to be joined
by Keith a little bit later.
He's from GoDaddy,
and he's built a platform on Amazon ECS
that he's going to talk about.
Thank you, guys.
With that, let's get started.
First, to set the context,
I wanted to lay the foundation
of the service that we're going
to be talking about today,
and that is Amazon ECS.
Amazon ECS is our fully managed container
orchestration service
that provides the easiest
way for organizations
to build, deploy, manage
containerized applications on AWS.
Even at the compute layer,
we offer a lot of flexibility.
You can run containers on EC2 instances,
you can even run them on your own hardware
with ECS Anywhere.
But the majority of our
customers run on AWS Fargate.
Fargate gives you the ultimate
simplicity with serverless.
We manage the compute completely.
You pay for what you use,
which means you're not bound
by EC2 instance ratios.
ECS Managed Instances
is a new offering that
we just came out with
in the last month,
that is a fully managed compute
that eliminates infrastructure management,
while giving you access
to a really broad set
of EC2 instance size.
This is great if you, ooh,
if you're looking for
specific EC2 instances,
like GPUs, or network-optimized instances,
or memory-optimized instances,
while still taking advantage
of some of the great aspects of Fargate.
Like the maintenance
and the patching and the scaling
that we take care of,
ECS Managed Instances a is a great option
when you need that specificity,
but you still want ECS
to take care of that operational burden.
Continuing on that theme
of removing the operational burden,
what makes ECS really unique
is that it is fully
managed and versionless,
there is no control
plane for you to manage.
There are no upgrades of the
control plane to coordinate,
no patching of the
control plane to schedule.
We handle all of that
operational complexity.
This is something that I've been hearing
from customers all week,
that is part of why they really love ECS
is that we handle so much
of that on their behalf.
When you create a cluster,
it is essentially just a logical grouping.
It is not really something
that you have to treat
as something precious.
It is, you can create as
many clusters as you want
and use them as you want to
in order to group services together,
because we're managing that control plane
and you don't have to think about it.
And if you're using Fargate
or Managed Instances,
you don't need to
provision or scale servers.
You don't need to manage
or patch the operating system.
We manage all of that on your behalf.
And specifically with Fargate,
you get tenant isolation.
And our financial services customers
really love this specifically
because the security boundary
becomes not the container,
but the EC2 instance,
because in Fargate, every task
gets a unique EC2 instance.
You can also achieve this
with ECS Managed Instances,
but you lose some of the
value of Managed Instances
and the optimizations that we're providing
with the bin packing and scaling
of the underlying instances.
And then we come to some
of the native things
that we've built into ECS.
So the first one being our
native service discovery.
This one I feel like is
kind of an underrated thing
that we have in ECS.
We build in service discovery
and a service mesh,
and that is Service Connect
is the name of the service.
You don't have to install, or patch,
or maintain Service Connect,
it is just there, and it's
available for you to use.
You have a unified way of
accessing all of your services.
You don't have to maintain DNS,
any complex management there.
It's available for you to set up
and access at any time.
Finally, native deployment mechanisms.
We've always had a deployment
mechanism (laughing) in ECS,
you've always been able
to update your services
using a rolling deployment mechanism,
but we found that a lot of customers
are going outside of ECS
to use other external
deployment strategies,
like CodeDeploy to do
blue-green, for example.
So just this past summer,
we launched native blue-green strategies,
as well as just about a month ago,
we launched canary and linear strategies
all natively within ECS.
And this is really important
because by making that native to ECS,
we're removing that burden
of, A, having to go outside of ECS
in order to set up that
deployment strategy,
but also all of the wiring
of the target groups
in order to set up the
blue and the green side,
all of that exists within ECS
and it just makes the deployment
of each of those things a lot simpler.
Now, all of those things brought together
are a lot of why
customers adopt ECS today.
And when you do adopt ECS,
you're in very good company.
Over three billion tasks are
launched in ECS every week.
Over 65% of all new
AWS container customers
use Amazon ECS.
And it is very heavily used
internally within Amazon.
We actually call Amazon ECS
one of our foundational services.
And the reason we call it that
is because every time we
stand up a new region in AWS,
ECS is one of the very first
services that has to go in.
And the reason is because
so many other AWS services
build their infrastructure using ECS.
So you're in good company
when you're using ECS.
So that's a little bit about the service
that we're talking about today.
I wanna hand it off to Tsahi
to talk a little bit about applications.
- Thank you, Jen.
So in the next part of the session,
I'm going to cover how actually
deploying apps to production
actually looks like.
But before we get there,
we need to understand
how deployment mechanism works.
I'm also going to shift in
between two perspectives.
One of those of the development team,
those who are building apps,
deploying them into production,
and the platform builders,
those who are building
tools and automation
in order to support the development teams
in order to get their job easier.
So let's look at the deployment process
from developers' point of view.
From the moment we have
our container image package
built into Amazon ECR,
the process of deploying
it into production
can be quite complex
and involve many different steps,
which I'm gonna cover in this slide.
It starts with having a networking,
so AWS VPC and Amazon
ECS cluster to provision,
which basically hold all of
our applications into it.
Then we need to have a way to tell ECS
what is the configuration of our app,
and we do it through
an ECS task definition.
That's the mechanism in order to do it.
And then a common pattern
of exposing an app
is usually through a load balancer,
an application load balancer.
And in order to do that,
we need to do it securely.
We need to have a TLS certificate,
we need to make sure we have that.
And then we need to integrate it
with the ALB itself,
alongside with all of its resources.
So target group, phishing rules,
routing configuration and so on.
And just now we got to a point
where we can integrate this all together,
create an easier service,
which basically takes the task definition
and creates multiple
instance of this task,
integrate them with the ALB,
and then expose the app
to the outside world.
But the thing is, our app
is not a static entity.
Of course, we need to have
an auto-scaling policies in place.
We need to take care of that.
And in order to operate and
maintain our app over time,
we need to be able to observe it.
So we need to ship
logs, traces and metrics
into the observability service.
In our case, it's Amazon CloudWatch.
And you could do it easily
with Container Insights,
which integrated with ECS.
Now, all of that complex process
is just for a single app.
If we flip the perspective around
and we look from a platform builder's,
we also have some other challenges.
There are many different development teams
that platform team
builders need to support.
Each come with its own application
and different requirements.
And even if we standardize
on the compute layer,
so, for example, if you
standard with Amazon ECS
to provision our resources,
each different app might need
a different backing service.
So, for example, some
might need an S3 bucket
and some might need a DynamoDB table.
And we need to be able to scale it
across the organization.
So it's not just about how
they're deployed single up,
it's how do I make sure
all the requirements
of the different teams are satisfied?
So like any good engineers,
we usually automate things.
And by automation, you
probably understand it,
is building developers' platform.
We need to a build tool,
a platform which will help developers
get their task easier.
Now, like any other system
or app in the organization,
it has to have design principles.
And today, I wanna cover three
important design principles
for building developer platforms.
Those are lifecycle management,
economies of scale and
break glass procedures.
So let's dive deep into
each of them separately.
Lifecycle management means
owning the entire lifecycle
of the deployment of the app
from the creation, through update,
all the way up to decommission.
It's not just about, "How
do I deploy the app?"
it's about maintaining it over time
with updates and upgrades.
It also includes some
sort of an entry point
for developers to be able
to interact with the system.
And this can be anything
from an API, a CLI,
or even a collection of templates,
which I will cover in the next part.
Economies of scale is all about
being smart with resources.
Don't provision things
that you don't need to.
And make sure you're
reusing things over time.
And this means reusing resources.
Like in the previous example,
if you have an ALB,
we don't need to provision another ALB
to expose a different app, a second app,
we can reuse the same ALB
with different routing configuration.
We also need to configure
shared resources.
So the ECS cluster,
the VPC configuration,
the monitoring dashboards,
we need all of that
to be shared across all
of the different apps.
And in reality, it's about balancing
between the approach of replicating things
for each and every app,
but avoiding the complexity
of having everything
interconnected that you create.
You can end up with a mess
of resources in your system.
And the last thing, which I
think is the most important one,
is the break glass procedures.
This is your escape hatches.
No platform is gonna be perfect
for every use case from the start.
And even if you graduate
and introduce more features,
you're not gonna hit all the marks
for all the deployments.
So you need to give your
users, the developers,
an easier way to transition
between platform offering.
So if they use one deployment method,
you wanna enable them to migrate
or move away in the future
into other deployment
methods within the platform.
We also want to enable them
to extend the platform capability.
So if the platform
doesn't support anything,
they can extend it with their
own customized tooling scripts
or anything else.
And the last thing is about
self-managing resources
in the future.
There might be a case,
and we've seen it with a lot of customers,
that users need to adopt
and need to self-manage resources
because they reach to a point
where have the very specific requirements
that the platform cannot provide them.
They need to be able to
self-manage those resources
instead of redeploying and
migrating out of the platform.
You don't want your users
to feel they are trapped
into the platform limitation.
And this brings us to
philosophical questions,
that is an ongoing one
between platform teams
and developer teams.
And it's all about,
how do you design the platform interface?
Should we use obstruction,
which is hiding the implementation
of the underlying component?
Or should we use composition,
which is all about combining
resources with default,
but exposing the underlying
implementation to the users?
Or maybe you should use a
mixture of both of them.
And whatever you choose,
it's basically impact
the way users understand
what's going on in the system.
In reality, it's a
balance of understanding
what going on or how the
things work under the hood
and achieving the user's goal,
which is, in our case,
getting from code to cloud.
So let's dive deep into
each of them separately.
With obstruction, users don't need to know
what's happening under the hood.
They can be free from any
implementation decision
and get started very quickly and easily,
getting the things they need.
This brings some advantages,
like having a really
low barrier for entry.
We don't need our users
to be an AWS expert.
They can just spin up, use the platform,
in order to deploy their own resources.
It also ensures consistency
across the organization.
Everyone using the same patterns,
everyone using the same
deployment mechanism
and it's easier to
understand what's going on.
And lifecycle management in this case
is usually exposed through an API,
which is an easier way
to interact with platforms.
Sorry.
However, it does come
with some challenges.
We do rely on platform teams
to provision to get new features.
So whenever we need to extend
the platform capability,
we need to wait for the
platform team to build this
and integrate it with the platform.
It also creates some challenges
when things go wrong.
When there's an error and we need to debug
or investigate something,
we ended up understanding
what the underlying resources actually are
and dig up into the actual configuration,
which kind of is the purpose
of having lower barrier for entry.
So this is another thing
we need to take into account,
and it also creates some
higher maintenance effort.
This is a system like any other app
and we need to ensure we
maintain this over time,
including updates, upgrades
and operation efficiency.
So in reality, it's a
simpler way to get started,
but evolution is bottlenecked
by the platform teams.
Composition on the
other hand is different.
It's all about automating the setup,
but keeping everything
visible for the users.
The good thing about that
that developers can use part
of what the platform gives them
and get the result they need.
They can do it, they can
adapt it very quickly,
and get slice and dice,
whatever the platform gives them,
and deploy to production.
Flexibility is also a positive thing here
because they can adjust whatever template
or whatever tooling they have
in order to get the result they need.
And what you see is what you get.
There's no hiding,
there's no hidden
implementation under the hood.
So meaning, when they
need to see something,
when they need to update something,
they can just do it easily.
However, this brings us a
couple of other challenges.
So it doesn't require
steeper learning curve.
You don't need to be an expert,
but you need to have domain knowledge
into the domain you're operating in.
So for example, in our case,
developers do need to understand
Amazon ECS Concept, ECS
Cluster, ALB, and so on.
It also creates fragmentation
around deployments.
Because each team can customize
their own deployment method,
this can lead to the fact that each one
have a different way of deploying things,
which in our case, from
a platform perspective,
it can be how to manage
across the organization.
And the last thing about
lifecycle management,
it can become tricky,
especially when we talk about templates,
it can become tricky
to scale this across the organization.
So the trade off here
is about requiring more domain
knowledge from the users,
but teams can evolve independently.
Summarizing these two approach,
it would be nice if we
can blend them together,
if we can provide a
simpler way to get started,
but without hiding the
implementation detail upfront,
when you need to update something,
you can still do it.
So let's look at the same entry point
of what we started at the beginning
of having an app deployed,
an app package in ECR
ready to be deployed.
If we could provide a
simple way to get started,
like a very light interface
that requires a couple of
parameters and no more,
but it does come with
a lifecycle management.
So every time we update something,
this kind of service take control
of the entire lifecycle operation.
And in turn, it provision
everything you've seen
in the previous site.
So the cluster, the VPC configuration,
the ALB and the integration
with CloudWatch.
But this is all kept visible to the users.
And whenever we have another
app in the organization,
it's automatically using the
same deployment mechanism
and integrate and reuse the same resources
that we already provision.
This approach balance between
the level of knowledge
needed to get started
and the flexibility to
change things in the future.
In the next part of this session,
Jenny's going to cover how Amazon ECS
can help you achieve all of that.
- Thank you.
Thank you, Tsahi.
I am so honored to introduce to you today
Amazon ECS Express Mode.
We introduced this feature just last week.
We made it for developers
to experience ECS in a whole new way.
Taking an advantage of all the things
that Tsahi just talked about,
of all the years of platform experience
that ECS has learned from
and pass that knowledge onto our users
so that you can stand up
your applications faster.
We started the way we do all applications
at products at Amazon,
we worked backwards from the customer.
And we found that most ECS customers
were implementing a
really repeatable pattern.
The same one that Tsahi
was showing earlier,
but a lot of that pattern
existed outside of ECS.
It included other AWS services,
like load balancers,
autoscaling, domain name certificates,
networking, observability.
So we asked ourselves
could we do what ECS does best
and relieve customers of that burden?
Could we take more responsibility?
Let me show you what we've done.
To create an app with
Amazon ECS Express Mode,
you only have to give us three things,
your container image
and two IM rolls.
We take defaults for everything else,
but there are additional
configurations available.
As soon as you complete the deployment,
you do get an application URL,
and that URL allows you
to test your application end to end.
Those options do allow you
to configure the application.
And we'll go through what
all those options are
in just a minute.
But they're greatly reduced
compared to the hundreds of parameters
that you would've had to go through
on all of these resources
that we are provisioning,
that I'm showing you on the screen now.
And Express Mode provisions
all of those resources you need
to stand up a highly available, scalable,
containerized service
using AWS best practices.
And those include things
like canary deployments,
alarm-based rollbacks,
TLS certificates, autoscaling policies,
CloudWatch logging, AZ rebalancing,
minimally permissive
inbound security groups,
all configured and wired together
so you don't have to think about it,
just to get started.
And at the end of this deployment,
you have a live application.
The command line view is
similarly very simple.
One container, two IM rolls.
The first IM roll is
the task execution role,
which if you're familiar with ECS,
you'll know is what we use
to get your container image from ECR
and to set up your logging.
The second one is new,
it's an infrastructure role,
and that's what we use to provision
all of the resources on the right.
And you might ask, how did
we come to this architecture,
the defaults that we selected?
And we were trying to
balance a couple of things.
So one, at AWS, we love data. (laughing)
So we looked at, what are
customers configuring today?
And this was a very common pattern.
Customers were configuring services
and not individual tasks.
They were hooking up load balancers,
and as opposed to other
types of networking.
Two, we took a look at the best practices
and we talked to our principal engineers
and solution architects,
and we had a lot of really
difficult conversations,
(laughing) a lot of heated conversations.
And we looked at, how
do we strike a balance
between helping customers
get started fast,
with dev workloads and test workloads,
and also making sure
that you're set up for the long term?
Because really we wanna make sure
this is a place that
you're not overburdened
by what you would need
in order to run a production workload,
but it's also a place
that you can get started
and know that you have everything in place
to run that production workload.
So we do things like set
up all of the subnets
that you would need and all of the AZs,
and make sure that we
turn on AZ rebalancing,
so that when you're ready,
you can just increase
your desired counts to three,
and now you are highly available
in three availability zones.
But we start with just one
so that you're not burdened
with so many tasks,
and how to deal with
the cost of all of that,
all of this is built around
trying to make things really simple
and easy to get started.
And this is something
we're really excited about,
something you don't see
often in the AWS CLI.
We know that a lot of developers
love working right in
your IDE or terminal.
If you add this monitor
resources flag to your call,
you'll get the following
interactive experience.
This is really similar to the console,
so you can see what's happening
in your ECS deployment
in a really super visual way.
And this is happening on the create,
the update and the delete
of an Express Mode service.
We feel like the observability
of something that,
to go back to what
Tsahi was talking about,
a composition is a
really important concept.
So in both the console
and the CLI experiences,
you're seeing the RN of
the resource, the status,
any events or errors that we're receiving
are being piped through to these views,
so that you have a really
robust understanding
of what's happening in the environment.
I just alluded to this,
but back to what Tsahi was saying
about lifecycle management,
Express Mode is a complete lifecycle.
There is a create, an update,
a delete of this experience.
And if you are content
with that experience,
you never have to learn about
the underlying resources.
You don't have to go look at your ALB,
or your target group,
or even understand what
all the settings are
in the task definition.
For novice users, this
can be a really great way
to experience launching containers.
We also do a lot of things here
that make things in ECS a lot simpler
than they are today.
Things like updating the port
or the health check.
If you've done that today in ECS,
you know that's a potentially disruptive
and really difficult thing to coordinate.
We handle all of that
for you in Express Mode.
Moving from a public service
to a private service, or vice versa,
is a matter of handing
us different subnets
and pushing update.
There's things that we do in Express Mode
that are very complex,
that become very simple.
Let me show you.
So for observability,
we show you the normal CPU and memory,
but because we have load balancer,
there's also target response time,
4XX/5XX.
You also get your application logs.
We added a new Resources tab
that you see in the timeline view,
but we also have the list of dupe links.
Now, for the update,
this is gonna show all
of the create options.
You have your container settings,
port health check, environment variables,
secrets, commands,
and the task roll that you can add
to access other AWS services via IM.
For compute, you have CPU
and memory, autoscaling,
we have CPU memory and requests,
min and max.
For networking, you have
subnets and security groups,
and you can also name your own log groups
and log stream prefixes.
When we delete, you can also
see the process of deleting.
We're gonna delete any resources
that are unique to that service.
You might be asking yourself
about infrastructure as code.
I would love to tell you
about that. (laughing)
On the left, we have
the full CloudFormation
of the Express Mode architecture.
And on the right,
we have the Express
gateway service resource
with the required parameters.
I'm really excited about that reduction.
I don't know about you. (laughing)
(audience member clapping)
Yeah, thank you, you can clap.
It's a silent session,
but you're still allowed
to clap. (laughing)
(audience clapping)
Here, we have the optional
parameters as well,
but I've highlighted
where you can bring in
your own resources,
like a cluster, or a
subnet, or a security group.
This gives you some flexibility
to bring your own definitions in.
And Tsahi also talked
about economies of scale.
And I am super pleased to share
that Express Mode services
that are deployed to
the same set of subnets
in the same account
will share ALBs.
We do this using host
header-based listener rules.
And not only do we share them,
we also scale them.
And what do I mean by
that? Let me show you.
So we have a load balancer here
that's been provisioned by Express Mode.
And in the listener,
you can see that we have
25 Express Mode services.
We can share an ALB with up
to 25 Express Mode services.
They also all have
unique TLS certificates.
Now I'm gonna go back to ECS
and to Express Mode,
and provision a 26th service
so we can see what happens.
Just pulling everyone's favorite
NGINX image here. (laughing)
And not even gonna wait for
the deployment to finish
because it's already gonna kick off.
We're gonna go back to the EC2 console,
look at the load balancers
and see that we have started provisioning
a second load balancer.
And so this is what I mean by
scaling the load balancers.
When you provision that 26 service,
we will provision a second load balancer.
When you delete the 26th service,
we will delete that second load balancer.
Anything that is unique to
the service will be deleted.
Now, there are a lot of services out there
that will take a container
and give you a URL.
There are even some in AWS today already.
So I don't wanna be shy about saying that.
But I do want to be clear
about what I think is really
unique about Express Mode.
And that is that you have access
to all of these resources
that are in your account,
and you have the ability to mutate them.
And because of that,
going back to what Tsahi was talking about
with abstraction and composition,
and if you disagree with me here,
I would love to go
and have a philosophical
discussion (laughing)
with you afterwards.
It might be kind of fun.
But I believe that Express Mode
is a composition within an abstraction.
You have the ability to
stay within the abstraction,
if you want to.
You never have to know what's underneath.
You get the simplicity of the abstraction
and you get to stay within
that world, if you want to.
But underneath that is a composition,
and you get access to all of the goodness
of that composition
and the flexibility of
that, if you want to.
Now, also, you don't have
to graduate or migrate
in order to get access to that.
And in many services
in order to go from one state to another,
you have to draw that hard line.
You have to say, "Okay, well,
I have to forfeit that simplicity
in order to get access to
that feature that I need,"
and not with Express Mode.
With Express Mode, if you want to go
and access that thing that you need,
you can go and turn that on,
you can go and configure that parameter,
and then you can come back to Express Mode
to continue updating your image,
or your autoscaling,
or whatever it is that you're
doing on a daily basis.
And I think that is very differentiating.
To me, that empowers you as a developer
to keep a simple model,
but also have access to the
full feature set of ECS.
ECS that has been around
for more than 10 years,
that has been operating
very large services
(laughing) for more than 10 years,
and all of these other services
that we're provisioning as well.
ALB is also a very
robust service in itself.
You're getting access
to all of the features of these services
in order to provision
whatever you need to do
with your application.
You're starting simple,
but you have access to whatever you need.
Let me show you a little
bit of what I mean.
So we're gonna take an
Express Mode service.
Go to the Resources tab
and make a change to the task definition.
So I'm gonna go right into the JSON.
In the ECS console,
you can actually edit the JSON.
So I'm gonna add a second
container definition.
This is what we call a sidecar,
if you're not already familiar.
A lot of customers in
ECS add login sidecars,
a common one is called Firelands.
So you can send your logs
to another destination
rather than CloudWatch.
And in order to update a service
or your task definition in ECS,
you need to create a new
task definition revision,
and then go and update your service.
So that's what we're doing here.
We've just updated the service
and we're watching that deployment happen
back in the Express Mode service view.
Now, what we wanna see now
that we've done that update out of band
from the Express Mode service,
is can we go back to Express Mode
and do another update
and make sure that that
change was persisted?
So we're gonna update the
image in Express Mode.
We just moved to the
latest in my ECR repo.
Go back to the JSON and look.
My image is the new one,
that's the latest SHA.
And then my second container
definition is there.
So that's kind of the power,
is that you have the ability
to make changes in these resources.
We will persist the changes,
and you can continue using Express Mode
for those simple updates
to everyday changes.
Like ECS itself,
Express Mode is available
at no additional charge.
You only pay for the resources
that are provisioned.
And in the context of this,
that it would be Fargate
and the ALB itself,
which we're helping distribute the cost of
across all of the services.
We showed the console,
we showed the CLI,
API, SDK,
we showed infrastructure as code.
It's also in the CDK as an L1 construct.
We launched Terraform last week,
and I'm super pleased
(laughing) to announce
that about two days ago, one day ago,
we launched a new GitHub action.
So you are able to take a GitHub repo,
use the other GitHub actions
to build that into a container,
push it to ECR,
and then use our action
to push it to an Express
Mode service and get a URL,
right from your repo.
So with that,
Express Mode was built for developers
to help them get started fast in ECS.
We've also been talking
to a lot of platform teams
who see this as a way
to accelerate their DevX
to give an experience to
their application teams,
or to stand up small POCs
for things that they care less about
what the architecture looks like.
So even if you're a platform team,
maybe consider checking it out.
But with that, I think we
also wanna take a look today
at how platform teams
are using Amazon ECS today,
and what are some best practices?
GoDaddy has done an excellent job of that,
Keith specifically,
and we're really excited
to show you what he's done.
He did not have access
(laughing) to Express Mode,
or ECS Managed Instances,
or native blue-green,
but I think I've certainly drawn
a lot of inspiration from what he's built.
So I'm excited for you to see it.
- Thank you, Jen.
Hi, everybody, my name
is Keith Bartholomew.
I am a principal engineer at GoDaddy.
As Jen said,
a lot of what I'm about to show you today
is how we've used ECS
to build a platform
for our GoDaddy engineers.
And we did all that before
features like Express Mode,
before their blue-green canary deployments
and before Managed Instances.
So everything that I'm about to see,
recognize that it's about 10 times easier
for you to do this yourself,
if you wanted to, okay?
We did it the hard way,
and now you get to do it the easy way.
So you may know of GoDaddy
as a domains registrar,
that is the oldest business,
that's put really what we're known for.
But today, we do a lot more than that.
We call our customers
everyday entrepreneurs.
They're the kind of person
who has a side hustle,
a business that they run on the side.
It's not their main source of income,
but it's something that they're
really passionate about.
And we provide services
that help these everyday entrepreneurs
do everything they need to do
to run a small business.
And so that does include
getting a domain name,
getting a website,
but also running an e-commerce storefront
or taking point-of-sale payments
at a farmer's market
or something like that.
And so we call all of those touch points
the Entrepreneur's Wheel.
Now, just like generative AI
has changed the way
that we, as engineers and
technical people, work,
it's also changed how our
everyday entrepreneurs
do the things they need to do.
So GoDaddy Airo is our
AI-powered experience
that runs the gamut of
every product at GoDaddy.
So from getting the
idea for a domain name,
to generating a logo and a website,
and even doing social media marketing,
we're taking these ideas,
those back-of-the-napkin business ideas
that seem out of reach,
and we're putting them
into these everyday entrepreneurs' hands
so that they can make every business idea
more accessible than it ever has been.
Now, behind all these innovations
are thousands of builders
working tirelessly
to stand up all of the services
that it takes to run something like this.
And so that's where I'm
excited to tell you today
about GoDaddy's decentralized
developer platform.
So it all starts with CI/CD
where our developers do kind
of whatever they want to.
So some of them are running
self-managed Jenkins clusters,
some of them will stand
up GitHub actions workers
when they need to.
And a few people have hand
rolled their own CI/CD things
because they think that's important.
Infrastructure, we really
wanna let developers choose.
So there's a little bit of ECS,
there's some EKS,
and some of our teams are
using OpenStack on-prem.
And security, we really
don't wanna get in their way,
and so we let them patch
their vulnerabilities
whenever they feel like it.
It's none of our business, right?
And observability, we've got people
who like Prometheus,
some people really enjoy that
and they wanna use that, that's fine.
Some people like Elastic,
and they can do that too.
This is a pretty
cringe-worthy slide, right?
Like, can we all agree
that this is not what we
want to see in a platform?
Yes, okay, so this is,
with some hyperbole,
this is roughly what it
looked like at GoDaddy
before we started building this platform.
And so we took a lot of the good things
that were happening in these things
and we brought them together
to make a centralized, unified platform
for all of our engineers.
So our engineers have access
to push-button hardened
private GitHub action runners
that are automatically hooked up
to our IM system that we have.
So they can just deploy
with only literally a push of a button.
Katana itself,
that's the name of our
infrastructure platform,
is a managed compute platform
that makes them like
have push-button access
to ECS Fargate services, ALBs,
and all the other supporting
things they need there.
We've unified our securities,
we work really closely
with our security and governance teams
to make sure that all the Lambda run times
get updated when they need to get updated,
that all of the ECR images
are free of their vulnerabilities
and things like that.
And we're able to do that
through a really close
coordination with that team.
And then centralized observability.
We have a grade-A, world-class
observability team,
who I'm so lucky to work with,
and they've done a lot of work
to make sure that everyone
using this platform
with zero config
gets all of their logs, traces and metrics
piped to our centralized
observability platform,
where they can then go
create dashboards and alarms,
and understand how their
applications are behaving.
So the way that most of our engineers
interact with this platform
is with this unified single pane of glass.
I know that's kind of an overused term,
but our developers really enjoy this.
And to underscore the value of this,
consider that there's over
2,000 engineers at GoDaddy,
and for each of those teams,
they're following the best practice
of having a dev account,
a test account, a stage
account and a prod account,
and we have some others in there as well.
And then also consider that
large organizations are messy.
Most engineers don't
work on a single project.
They kind of share their time
with three, four, or five projects
since we have engineers
who need access to 30 AWS accounts,
and they need to deploy that application
to 30 different AWS accounts.
Going around and clicking
through all the AWS consoles
can be pretty tiring.
And so we've brought all that together
where our engineers have
a single place to look
to see, "How is this service doing?
How did that rollback happen?
What were the logs that happened
from ECS when this failed?
How is this being impacted
by an outage with a different app?"
They're able to get all that
together in a single place.
They also use GitHub actions,
which we manage a lot
to do the same things
from more of an automated CI perspective.
This unified dashboard
really comes into play
and is really valuable
when it comes to observability.
I can't tell you how many
times I've been paged
and I get on the phone
call with the product team
and the first thing that
I see on the screen share
is this screen.
They're looking at this
to see how, "Is the load
balancer in US East 1
compared to the load
balancer in US West 2?
Are these error rates spiking over here?
Are they idle over here?"
And our developers really
enjoy using this as a way
to understand at a
really big-picture level,
how is everything of
across multiple accounts,
multiple services, how's
everything behaving?
We've also built generative AI support.
So even though we've gone through
a lot of effort to make our
platform as simple as we can
and easy for any engineer to understand,
it's still complicated, right?
And there's some times when
there'll be an ECS failure
that we can't really wrap or abstract,
and so we just have to show
them the direct failure from ECS
and the engineer doesn't really
understand what that means.
And so we've built an agent
right into that dashboard
that you just saw
that has access to a
bedrock knowledge base
with all of our documentation
as well as information about
how we specifically tailor
our infrastructure to their needs.
And it's able to use
tools and function calling
to reach into their account and live see,
"Okay, how is your ECS service doing?
Let me read the deployment events.
Let me read the CloudFormation events
and understand how that's going."
And then it provides our
users with a very detailed,
not generic and actionable statement
that they can then use
to self-resolve their problem,
or in some cases,
they'll even use this with another tool
to come create a ticket
in our support channel
where they can bring an entirely
pre-triaged incident to us
and then we can start
working on a support issue
when we need to there.
So it's been very, very powerful for us.
So at this scale, right,
we've got hundreds and
hundreds of AWS accounts,
accessing all those accounts is essential.
Obviously we need to be able to see
what's going on in them as a platform,
to understand how the
health of our many services
that we're managing,
our users need to see that information,
and we need to do that securely.
And so the way that we've done this
is by installing an agent.
And this is not the AI kind of agents.
We named it that before
they took that word from us.
The old-style agent,
we run one of those in each account.
And that agent comprises an API
gateway and several lambdas.
And we chose these because
they're very low cost to run.
When they're idle, they
consume practically $0.
I think we paid maybe like a penny
for the S3 code for the Lambdas.
And that's great because
it means that someone
who's using the platform
and using us for our
management capabilities,
they're not taking on an undue burden
just to use the platform.
so the control plane of what we're doing
is as low cost as possible.
But security is also critical here.
And so API gateway allows
us to use IM authentication
for that entry point,
where we can say only the IM role
in our dedicated management account
is allowed to invoke this API gateway.
And all that happens
without me writing a single line of code.
And I can't tell you how much
that helps me sleep at night
knowing that my code (laughing)
did not contribute to any problems.
I trust the AWS IM engineers
much more than I trust myself.
But we also then limit the things
that this agent can do, right?
So this is not carte blanche access
to everything within the account.
We need to get select
information about ECS,
about CloudFormation, about ALBs,
but other things that are
not any of our concern,
there are not lambda handlers
that are capable of doing that.
So we're limiting our
blast radius in that way.
And really the only right
operations that we do
are managing CloudFormation stacks,
or what else do we do?
We restart ECS services from time to time
if you just need to,
sometimes rebooting fixes the problem.
What our engineers get
from all this though
is push-button resilience.
So 2,000-plus engineers,
they come from a wide
range of backgrounds.
Some of them are really,
really good DevOps engineers,
they're intimately familiar
with every AWS product,
they're certified.
Some of them could not
tell you the difference
between an ALB and an NLB.
And we need to make sure
that all of those engineers
get the same experience.
So it all starts with Route 53 records
that ensure that anyone
who's running on our system
is able to get latency-based
routing between regions
and then failover between those regions
whenever there's an outage.
And so some of our teams are operating
in four and five different regions.
Some are just in two.
It really depends on their needs.
They don't have to
configure this failover,
they get it out of the box.
Those Route 53 records
then point to the networking resources
that take you into the application.
In most cases, that's an ALB.
We've also got teams
who are using CloudFront
to help sort of provide
more of a point-of-presence
at the edge.
And so we're integrating all that
directly with the Route 53 records.
And then you get down
finally to the ECS service.
And so for each deployment,
we're running a new ECS service,
and then we allow some
fairly complicated routing
from the ALB to the service,
where engineers can either do 50/50 splits
if they're doing an A/B test,
or they can use a 5% split for a canary,
or something like that.
So they're able to get a lot of these
really kind of detailed
and fairly complex deployment strategies,
again, at the push of a button.
So key to that, what I was just mentioning
with these deployments,
every deployment on Katana
creates a new ECS service.
And we do this so that we
have a really reliable,
sort of warm standby
in the case of any bad things happening.
So let's say here
that version one of my service
is what's running in production.
And so all of my users
are going to version one,
and as little as possible,
I really don't want to
touch that service, right?
It's like the "Indiana Jones
and the Temple of Doom."
Like if it's not broke, don't fix it.
And so we don't want to touch service one,
but the development team
is working on version two,
they're making some changes
and they need to deploy that.
And so when they finally
make that deployment
and they deploy version two,
it stands up a completely
isolated ECS service,
a completely isolated target group,
and service one is not touched at all.
It stays exactly pristine
the way that it was.
Now, you do need to know
that version two is working.
And so with a specific header,
we have like x-version-2,
or a query stream that says x-version-2,
or even a cookie,
you could have your QA team
test version two of the application,
or you could run automated smoke tests
against version two of your application
to prove that it's working
the way that you want it to.
And then finally, when
you're confident with that,
you make a small change.
And the only thing that changes
is we change a target group
to point to version two
and not version one.
Again, version one has not been touched,
we're just moving traffic away from it.
You can do this all at once
if you want to go YOLO,
or you can do it slowly
with a percentage route
to sort of ramp traffic up to version two
of the application. And
so then, in this case,
we've got version one
running as a warm standby.
So if when it comes under load,
version two starts to have a degradation,
version one is still there as a fallback.
Again, this is just
built into the platform.
This is a fairly complicated way
to manage deployments,
and our engineers don't think about this
on a day-to-day basis,
but they have used it in
some really creative ways
to have live preview environments.
Sometimes they're not just
running two versions at a time,
they're running five, six,
up to a dozen I think I've seen,
where they've got really busy teams
who are constantly testing
things and deploying these
using these sort of dark release patterns.
Now, as Tsahi and Jen both mentioned,
escape patches are really
important for a platform, right?
I think we've made a lot of good choices
about the correct kinds of abstractions.
And in most cases, that works,
but every now and then,
people need to sort of grow up from that
or they have something
that they really want to do
in their own specific way.
And so one example of the way
that we do this is with WAF.
So every load balancer that
we provision has a WAF ACL.
And I'm not sure if you've ever configured
a WAF ACL on your own,
but they're fairly complicated,
like the JSON language
for expressing rules
and bypasses and the orders,
it's a lot.
It was a whole day of
documentation reading for me.
And so we don't require our
users to know all of that.
We just say, "You know what?
Most of you're going to need a rate limit.
You're going to need to allow
and block certain subnets.
We're going to give you AWS Managed Rules
to prevent common attacks.
But if you find that your app
really needs a large
body size and a request,
you can opt out of those things
as it meets your needs."
And so most of our users are
very successful with this,
and they never touch the
JSON language of A WAF ACL,
but every now and then we get someone
who has a really complicated IP set
and they need to do something
that this doesn't support.
And instead of trying to build
that into the abstraction
and slowing them down while
we build these features,
we just say, "Okay, go
create your own WAF ACL,
tell us the RN of the
ACL that you created,
and we'll associate that
with the load balancer,
and then we move on."
And so they're able to take control.
They inherit the
responsibility for the WAF ACL,
and they don't have to
sacrifice any of their benefits
they get from the rest of the platform.
They continue using all
that as they did before.
We do this with a few other
things too. So security groups,
we'll automatically
configure security groups
to allow the things that we
manage to talk to each other.
But if they have a
complicated security group,
they can pipe that in,
or IM policies,
we'll let them define
that in line if it works.
And then sometimes those policies
get a little bit large to manage,
and so we just say, "Okay,
just tell us the RN of your policy
and we'll attach it to the task role.
Everyone at GoDaddy uses CDK.
We have centralized on
CDK as our management tool
for all of our AWS infrastructure.
And it's very common for
us to find developers
that use Katana for what it's good at,
but then they need to extend it,
they need to associate that ECS task
with a DynamoDB table,
or they want to change
the behavior of something.
And so they're able to use constructs
to extend what Katana provisions
within their own CDK code.
And so you could say,
"I'm gonna create a
new Katana environment.
This is actually just looking up
and adding to context values.
What do I have here?
The listener RN gets a random string
that they can't predict ahead of time."
And so we'll look that up live,
get that context in there,
and then they can use
this piece of context
to add their own custom
listener rule later,
and take the infrastructure
that we've managed
and augment it in a way
that meets their needs.
So all these guardrails and
off-ramps are very important.
It's all built around a governance system
that I think one of my colleagues
in the row over here is using.
We use CloudFormation hooks to restrict
what people are able to do
so that developers really
can't step a foot wrong.
So you can't create an ECS service
that has a public IP,
it just doesn't happen.
And Katana builds on top
of this governance system,
which gives us a lot of confidence
that we're not going to do
something wrong as a platform,
and anything that you
do within the platform
is going to adhere to these rules.
Like I said, we're all
using a common CDK tool set,
and so that gives us
sort of a lingua franca
to use between teams.
CDK is the way that we communicate.
The Katana managed infrastructure itself
is actually a very, very
large CDK application.
And so, in some cases,
users are able to just
learn from our code,
and I'm fine with that.
They can steal the source code
and say, "Ah, I see what you did there,"
and apply it to their own things.
And then there's no magic.
So there's nothing that our platform does
that users could not do themselves.
We don't have magic permissions,
we don't have any elevated things
that we can do this, but you can't,
because only we're trusted to do it.
We're doing things that
users could do themselves
and we're just accelerating
their path to do that,
which gives them a
really powerful off-ramp.
So if they ever needed to take
one of our CloudFormation stacks
and manage it themselves separately,
they can do that,
and they'll have no issues doing that
within our governance framework.
Now, at a company of GoDaddy's size,
managing infrastructure is important,
but really where our engineers
start to see the value
is in how we glue that infrastructure
to the rest of the business.
So like I said, we have a
very good observability team,
and out of the box,
every one of the ECS
services that Katana manages
has a fluent bit sidecar
that uses Firelands to send their logs
to our observability system.
We're working on a shared OTel collector
that collects those traces
and does the same thing there.
And this is huge for our engineers,
they don't have to do
anything to get this benefit,
it's just there for them.
Compliance and security, like I mentioned,
we work really closely with those teams
to make sure that everything
is always patched constantly.
And because of our kind of
oversight of the entire platform,
we're able to do this at a scale
that individual teams
can't do on their own.
GoDaddy's a big certificate registrar
or certificate issuer and DNS.
And so we work with our
internal certificate API
to let the engineer who's
provisioned their certificate
get that imported to the right AWS account
so that it works with their load balancer
and get those renewed automatically.
And then experimentation,
experimentation is a huge
part of the DNA of GoDaddy,
and you might think of experimentation
as just a front-end
concern of just A/B testing
in a browser,
but we believe that even
infrastructure changes
are experiments as well.
Version two of my application
might solve a performance bottleneck
that version one had,
and that might improve
a click-through rate
on a checkout funnel or something.
And so every time a new
application is deployed
or a new instance,
a version of an application
is deployed on Katana,
we send that data to our
experimentation platform
so that our data scientists
can correlate that
with their hypotheses
and other data sources
to see how that feeds into that.
And then enterprise networking is tricky,
it's messy, we've got a mix
of AWS accounts on-prem.
I think if you need on-prem
access, I know how to do it,
you have to attach yourself
to a certain subnet group,
something like that.
For our users, it's a checkbox.
We do these things to
work with those teams
and make sure that networking
is as easy as we can make it.
Now, why ECS Fargate?
There's a lot of compute platforms at AWS,
many of them support containers,
which is good for us.
We chose ECS Fargate
because it really met the happy medium
for cost, management
and flexibility for us.
Management is very important.
So we have a small team
that runs our platform,
about seven or eight engineers,
and we have 2,100 engineers
that we have to serve.
So if we are patching
EKS instances every day,
can't do it, it's not manageable
to do that at that scale.
So ECS Fargate gives us the ability
to not have to manage or
patch those instances.
And like I said, this was invented
before ECS Managed Instances,
which changes that a little bit.
But we also don't have
to deal with scheduling
or anything like that.
And as someone who has previously
run Istio exactly once,
I can tell you that this
is (laughing) so nice
not to have to do that.
But we don't sacrifice
anything with our flexibility.
So they still have full access
to all their container
settings, to VPC connections,
things like Service Connect.
And it's a good cost fit
for the kind of services that we run,
because we have a lot of
always-on, customer-facing web apps
that work really well for
the way that ECS is parked.
So finally, our lessons learned.
Our users really value
the single pane of glass.
I underestimated how much
they would enjoy that.
Operating via CloudFormation
is kind of difficult.
CloudFormation has a very static way
of expressing infrastructure,
and ECS services are very dynamic.
You'd make a deployment
and that creates hundreds of events
and it's checking health checks,
so there's quite a bit going on there.
And so getting the impedance
to match between those things
has been something that we've
had to put some work into.
But it does have its perks.
If we ever get ourselves
backed into a corner,
we can move traffic away from a region,
delete all the stacks,
recreate them exactly
the way they were before,
and the app is running as we want it to.
And we have to partner with other teams.
We kind of call ourselves
a platform of platforms.
We're all thinking with
a platform mindset,
but I can't fix everything myself.
And so working with our
observability teams,
our security teams, our governance teams,
has really been essential
to making a platform that meets the needs
that our developers have.
And so I'll lead you,
we had our philosophical tension.
So there's one more philosophical tension
to share with you.
I think it'd be a big mistake
to think of your developers
as one kind of person,
to say that, on this spectrum
of being an AWS expert
or an AWS newbie,
that there's only one kind
of engineer at your company.
You're obviously gonna find people
who exist all across that.
And so what we found is
that, to meet their needs,
you have to understand that
they have a wide spectrum
and build a platform that
meets all of those needs,
that allows the AWS experts to thrive
and have the control that they want,
and that allows the
less AWS-centric people
to get the job done
without having to know everything,
or get certified, or anything like that.
So as you leave,
if you're going to
consider building platforms
or if you're working on
a platform of your own,
please consider making your platform
meet as wide of a
spectrum of your engineers
as you possibly can
so that you can get success
for a wide range of people.
And I'll hand it back to Jen.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
- [Audience Member] Whoo.
(Jen laughing)
- I'll say it again,
I feel like I've drawn so much inspiration
from what Keith has built from Katana.
I know we're already thinking about things
we wanna add to our roadmap
from some of the things that he's done.
So I thank you again, Keith,
for sharing what you've built.
I hope you gained a lot from this session.
Please try out ECS Express Mode.
I hope you you've learned a little bit
about accelerating
application development,
about building platforms on ECS.
Check out this QR code.
It is specific to this session.
You can download a PDF of the slides.
We also have a link to the
ECS Immersion Day workshop,
which now includes ECS Express Mode.
And we also have a link
to the GitHub action
that we just launched.
Thank you again, and please
fill out the session survey.
Thank you.